[Music]
here's your money briefing for Thursday
June 1st I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
a plan to invest thousands of dollars in
a trust account for babies as a way to
fight poverty as being considered by
several States Wall Street Journal
reporter Brenda Leon joins us to discuss
how it would work so JR this investment
program began to gain support when two
economists first envisioned this idea
that a policy recommendation could
address the racial wealth Gap the
widening racial wealth Gap in our
country the idea then began to gain
traction when Hillary Clinton also
floated the idea of a federal program
during her 2008 presidential bid so
what's the purpose of this program of
creating trust funds for babies so the
purpose is to
widening wealth Gap so that families who
are already in the lower income brackets
could access capital for their
children's future there are demographics
who might have less access to Capital
less access to resources and as a result
of that then these families have a
harder time to access things like
education a home or perhaps even start a
business all right so how would this
work how would money be paid to babies
so the money wouldn't be paid out
directly to babies but rather an account
would be created by the government and
funded accordingly and throughout the
child's life this account would be
invested and it's expected to grow who
would qualify to receive the money so
children from low-income families would
qualify to receive these accounts
however some proposals have tied these
conditions for families to qualify if
for example they receive public benefits
like Medicaid now these so-called baby
bonds have been discussed in at least
eight states and lawmakers in Washington
DC Connecticut and California have
approved the programs though they're not
actually in effect yet what's holding
them up funding Jr funding is holding
them up while there's been several bills
introduced by Democratic leaders around
the country a lot of the times the
program is solved because funding is the
most important ingredient to make a
program like this possible but also to
continue the program throughout the
future now when you're reporting you
highlight the baby investment program in
Connecticut how would it work there in
Connecticut if the proposed program
which is still slated for a legislative
approval the program would fund accounts
for children born under Medicaid
specifically with an initial deposit of
thirty two hundred dollars now these
thirty two hundred dollars are expected
to grow as a nest egg and a first-time
family would also qualify for
eligibility under the state's public
health insurance program and that
eligibility is capped at a family with
an income of sixty five thousand dollars
roughly the overall numbers are with
stalling these programs so for example
in Connecticut the program would cost
600 million dollars and it would fund
accounts for children born in the next
12 years
however these accounts would have one
initial deposit of thirty two hundred
dollars and the fund would be invested
by the state so thirty two hundred
dollars for the first 12 years of a
child's life that comes out to almost
forty thousand dollars are there rules
surrounding how and when that money can
be accessed so when a child is 18 years
old they could take this money and use
it towards education a business or home
after a required financial literacy
course now these were the parameters set
by lawmakers when they proposed this
initial program so this on purpose
written into the rules here absolutely
so the importance of financial literacy
throughout a family's life is a
component that's added on to the program
and the idea is also that in order for
families to manage wealth they need to
have the wealth and the necessary tools
to continue to build their NASDAQ what
lawmakers also have in mind is
incentivizing the local economy so
families would be required to stay in
Connecticut in order for them to access
the fund in the future but also it could
help them leverage the economy by
families buying homes and families
opening businesses in Connecticut and
even accessing an education which has in
turn been a factor of building
generational wealth now these investment
or trust accounts have gone into effect
in several other countries how do they
work there well they actually work in
several different ways in Singapore they
offer per child grants aimed at
increasing fertility rates in Canada
low-income children are eligible for an
education investment Fund in Israel
children receive savings accounts
regardless of income and in the UK child
trust accounts were funded for about a
decade starting in 2002 and then they
switched to tax-free savings accounts
that's Wall Street Journal reporter
Brenda Leon and that's your money
briefing I'm Jr for the Wall Street
Journal
[Music]